hey everyone I'm Adi from Abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by trade and
I'm gonna be talking about one of the
most popular fitness and health
influences on YouTube
Whitney Simmons I have had so many
people ask me to check out her diet and
review her now before I get today's
video I want to mention that a lot of
you guys ask me what is in my cup and
this week I partner with trade to get
mama the good stuff you all know I love
my coffee even though I'm on decaf now
but the flavour and routine of having my
like almond milk latte is just so
comforting to me so trade works with
over 50 of the nation's best Coffee
Roasters to compile over 400 different
ethically sourced coffees you basically
fill out this online survey about your
likes and your dislikes and how you
prepare your coffee like espresso or
drip and they match you with your
perfect dream coffee I am all about
customization and I love trying out new
coffees whenever I'm at like a little
boutique coffee shop so this is
literally my kind of program not to
mention the prices were really
reasonable and they delivered right to
my door I had a lot of packages in the
mail but I was particularly jazzed about
getting coffee so this is the After
Hours high-wire decaf coffee which I
mean if I were a coffee snob I would say
has notes of sweet vanilla and nut but
no really honestly if you like a full
bodied espresso that has a sweeter cocoa
flavor you've got to hit this up I
brewed this in my espresso maker and
topped it off with some steamed almond
milk but it is totally delicious anyway
now if you're a coffee lover like me
you're going to want to click in the
link in the description because trade is
giving the first 100 people who click
the link below 30% off of your first
coffee yay copy ok so let's get back to
our wedding today
so Whitney is a 26 year old fitness
enthusiast who was inspired by her
father to get back in the gym as a way
to combat her depression since then
she's a mass over 2.9 million Instagram
followers and 1.8 million YouTube
subscribers so it's safe to say that she
is massively influential and inspiring
in the fitness world now before I begin
with her what I eat
day I just want to say that I legit love
Winnie's positive attitude she is so fun
to watch and easygoing and I can really
see why so many people totally resonate
with her she recently came out with a
video that discusses her history with
restrictive eating and how she's
transitioned to an intuitive style of
eating so kudos to that and finally a
general disclosure here that the
information you're about to see is for
education and entertainment purposes
only and you should always seek advice
from your health care team for your
unique case okay so before we get into
the actual wedding day let's see what
happened when Whitney looked back at
some of her old what I in a day videos
we asked you to do this on her youtube
channel except for she followed her last
slow date eating's
I kind of took a peek at some of the
food I was eating back in the day
there's absolutely no way neckin mom
survived so I decided not to follow them
but kind of talk through them see the
changes that I'd made since then and
kind of just my thoughts on what I used
to think was the ideal perfect full day
of eating I can tell I was still so
scared of carbs like protein was my only
goal girl and I was so scared of oatmeal
so I had one packet of oatmeal with
Greek yogurt and strawberries I don't
even show me making it so it's very
confusing these girls who were so skinny
and tiny that's all I wanted to be in
over the last few years we've seen this
huge shift of when we just want to be
strong women just want to lift weights
now I'm trying to get big like now we
had this whole thick move marriages the
beautiful movement I've really learned
over the last few years to stop being so
restrictive so as you can see I think
Winnie has really grown over the past
few years and her relationship with food
and her body has really flourished I am
so so happy to see that and I totally
commend her for being so brave and
acknowledging some of the potentially
damaging kind of skinny at any cost
culture that she was ultimately
promoting I think that it's so easy to
think that youtubers are perfect and
never struggle but that is like hardly
if not ever the case trust me
honestly I often worry that even I'm
guilty of that but
in reality I'm like kind of a hot mess
but more on me later let's get into her
what a midday Thursday a body blue has a
lot of free of probiotics and is must
help with digestion below D your skin
I'm turning it out thank you Sarah says
he for sending it my life listen I hate
things that taste like health and this
tastes like health but it also tastes
pretty fruity light crisp it's helped my
digestion so much so I've been taking it
first thing in the morning okay love
that she's like keeping it real and she
also hates foods that tastes like health
but also there is a lot of emerging
research on pre and probiotics
prebiotics are the non-digestible foods
that we eat which of course help to feed
the bacteria in our gut and probiotics
are the bacteria they're those live
microorganisms that colonize our gut so
common examples of prebiotic foods are
things like bananas Jerusalem artichokes
garlic chicory root onions and asparagus
and common examples of probiotic food
sources include things like yogurt
kimchi sauerkraut tempeh and kefir you
can also get both prebiotics and
probiotics in the form of supplements
which sounds like what this Sara's day
product is however because there are so
many different probiotic strains out
there science still hasn't totally
identified the ideal combination and
there are some concerns that probiotics
may negatively alter your gut microbiome
or be risky for certain populations like
those with you know immune compromised
problems in my experience some people
respond really really well to probiotics
and some people not so much
I personally use them a lot one
traveling taking antibiotics or any
medications that mess with my digestion
so if it's working for you keep at it
sounds like it's working for Whitney so
that's amazing but just know that a
supplement is not necessarily essential
for everyone and ideally you want to be
working with a registered dietician to
find the right strain for you all right
now I'm looking forward to some food
I could have a meal every day for
breakfast I would but then you guys are
like oh no not again
you know like I feel you girl there is a
ton of pressure that comes with working
in the online world honestly I believe
that the optimal diet is a varied diet
however if a meal is what you're feeling
you shouldn't hold back the best thing
you can do for yourself is really to
find a lifestyle that you can stick to
and I get that for some of us we just
like routine
I love routine because I'm super type-a
and also I'm super busy and let's be
real planning a variety of permutations
takes more work and time and brain space
right I mean it's something I personally
challenge myself to do but I have to
make it a priority so having said that I
would wait rather you have the same
nutrient rich breakfast every day
then skip breakfast because it's too
much work to strategize a different meal
every day so girl I support your oatmeal
game let's see what you got listen I've
never learned how to make hash browns
okay it's so difficult the instructions
say put it down and then flip on once
this brown on one side but that doesn't
work for me you know it never works so
shout out to my friend Colby he taught
me how to make them okay he came over
here we're having a double date him and
Nicolette's showed up he just started
flipping out these hash browns they're
the best hash browns I've ever had so
the trick is to never let the hash
browns sit so I'm just throwing here you
know getting all warm but then I keep
stirring them up then I'm gonna add some
spices splash of water they'll be ready
to go and then over here I'm gonna be
cooking up some eggs I'm gonna pop two
eggs - Eggs and there I've been awaiting
to try this with you guys
okay the brand new Trader Joe's
everything but the bagel Greek style
yogurt did I'm so excited I'm gonna add
some of that cheese to the hashbrowns
got my bread toasted over there listen
the reason I love oatmeal is because
oatmeal is just quick and easy but
sometimes we got have switched up you
guys encouraging me to switch it up soft
switch
[Music]
breakfast complete girl that is like a
badass breakfast that looks amazing but
for a nutrition perspective I also love
it it provides me with a great source of
energy that she needs to tackle her day
it's got complex carbs and the potatoes
and the bread healthy fats and the
avocado and a good source of protein in
the eggs I also love that she's adding
extra spices to her hash browns because
you know spices do help us cut back on
some of the need for added salt I mean
if she wanted to add in a little bell
pepper onion or the hash browns it would
kind of help her sneak in a little
veggie at breakfast but in general I
kind of wish this was my breakfast today
also I am obsessed with everything about
the bagel seasoning that stuff goes on
everything and I'm dying to get to the
states this winter so I can get my hands
on that dip Trader Joe's come to Canada
I will support you all on my own
but don't worry baby we have time for a
snack I'm very sad to say that I do not
have time for a snack but that's okay
I'll see you guys back here for lunch
I got hit up said sweetie I can't be
late no snack honestly though as a mom I
can totally relate to not having time
for a snack all the time but if you find
yourself in this situation a lot I
really do try to recommend putting aside
some kind of on-the-go snacks that you
can just grab as you Russia at the door
so for me so my favorites are things
like homemade protein bars energy bites
protein pancakes a piece of fruit and a
yogurt cup even just like a handful of
nuts or seeds and I will leave some
links below to my go-to recipes for some
of those really fast on-the-go snacks
but now I'm hungry for lunch so get at
me so I chopped up three sweet potatoes
now normally I would put cinnamon on my
sweet potatoes but Paige she's gonna
raving about adding some taco seasoning
I'm gonna go ahead
cook up the Trader Joe's daily slice
chicken breast seasoned with an
authentic breasts oh I'm so happy to
report okay that I have finally
purchased it instant pot listen whoever
well but I've been intimidated by it
okay it's a very intimidating device but
my favorite thing to use it for right
now is cooking up chicken like this in
10 minutes eight minutes and that blows
my mind throw that in a bowl with the
sweet potatoes that I'm cooking up and I
really just gotten in the habit of
always having a container of black beans
with chickpeas and then another
container with corn so then tomorrow for
lunch I can have the exact same thing
take out my containers pop it into a
bowl warming up and then it's just super
easy on the go alright so I did a base
of lettuce if you're looking for more
carbs and swap that out with your
favorite rice we all know I love jasmine
rice but today I went with the Twitter
Joe's a butter lettuce and I bought the
other day have a whole side of sweet
potatoes with the taco seasoning on it
which I actually haven't read yet it's
really good it's spicy
Oh basic lettuce added the corn black
beans chickpeas then the shredded
chicken that chicken shreds so well how
does that entire chicken cook in six
minutes I don't get it and then I added
cucumbers and red onion because I add
cucumbers a red onion to everything
usually I want a dressing but sometimes
if it gets a little bit dry then I'll go
ahead and add salsa my favorite salsa
okay everyone totally agree with Whitney
you need to drop what you're doing and
get yourself an instant pot because your
instant pot will become your BFF and you
know one of the classic healthy eating
recommendations that basically everyone
makes is to plan ahead right I say it I
do it sometimes but I'm also like crazy
busy some days and also totally not
perfect so sometimes even I've totally
forgot but these instant pot geniuses
you like throw everything in and it's
ready in under 30 minutes so I'm gonna
leave an affiliate link to the insta pot
down below so if you don't have one you
get yourself one
but honestly let's talk about the food
the lunch looks amazing this woman like
knows how to been
old a balance bowl so we've got the
complex carbs and fiber from the sweet
potatoes and the veggies
we got the protein from the chicken and
the beans there is like a solid portion
of protein right here probably around
like sixty grams which is quite a lot
for a lot of people so she could if she
wants you swap out some of the chicken
for maybe some avocado to up the healthy
fats I also personally love using
plant-based protein as kind of like my
base protein and then using animal
protein like chicken a little bit more
like a garnish so remember a while ago
when I was talking about condom meat and
like everyone here in the studio was
totally making fun of me this is like
what I'm talking about so this will save
you money and you get more of the
benefits of plant-based protein in your
life okay but honestly Winnie that meal
looks amazing super tasty really
satisfying and state shading and also I
love that it's meal prep friendly
okay snack time friends I don't know cuz
you might be addicted like I am these
are from top corners kettle corn sweet
salty they're so stinking good but they
get me in trouble you know cuz I just
please my feet the whole bag
post-workout sometimes I'll have a
protein shake if I don't have food
readily available since I'm waiting for
my dinner to cook up right now I'm gonna
hold myself over with them
top corners I feel about supplements you
don't need them but sometimes they will
aid you if I'm ever low on protein this
is just a really quick fix to get my
protein up for the day have a quick
little protein shake
okay so I've had the pop corners and I
agree that the sweet and salty kettle
corn flavor is the best I do find them
like they can't like they get stale too
quickly that's my interpretation I'd
weigh your other have like real kettle
corn popcorn but I can understand the
appeal okay so I'm assuming she's
probably had like maybe a cup of these
before dinner so she's probably getting
around 20 grams of carbs right there and
that snack but if you're craving that
that crunch factor it's definitely a
really great option I also really like
the fact that she's not a super hardcore
stickler for like serving sizes and like
measuring things out because of course
what first they can be really helpful it
seems like Whitney's gonna really
grasp on her hunger cues and is really
able to eat them freely without
completely ruining her appetite before
dinner now because there's a
protein-rich dinner like on the way I
would say for most people you wouldn't
necessarily need to have this amount of
protein so close to a meal but since she
did just get home from a workout it is
optimal to have around 20 to 30 grams of
protein within a 30-minute window after
a workout so I definitely can understand
the rationale for for kind of wanting to
sneak that in also did I just hear a
fitness influencer say that you do not
need supplements and like not try to
sell me their own brand of sketchy
supplements I live this fitness unicorn
okay but like honestly supplements are
really just that they are supplements
they're meant to supplement your diet as
needed not to replace whole foods and
part of eating intuitively is knowing
that every day is not going to be
perfect it's not going to be the same
and supplements can help fill those
occasional gaps but they really
shouldn't be used as like a crutch to
undo a generally poor unbalanced diet
they may also help to kind of complement
or enhance the effects of a balanced
diet or service adjuncts to traditional
medicine and certain populations I
personally take a lot of supplements but
I don't push them on people and I really
really love that Winnie is acknowledging
that they really should not be your
first line choice for good nutrition
thank you maybe you rock all right Deena
tan beyond me beyond beef clip we
screwed a whole pound of it I found a
whole recipe to make meatballs with it I
don't have a lot of the ingredients so
I'm just gonna make it work with some
garlic onion salt pepper I'm missing
like breadcrumbs parsley parmesan all I
got is Mexican but we're gonna make it
work okay we're gonna do our best here
[Music]
here she is the spaghetti squash the
beyond meat meatballs the spaghetti
squash cooked perfectly
30 ish minutes till makes it a little
bit crunchy not too mushy topped it with
tomato basil sauce delicious okay so
first of all love that she just like
freestyled that meal even though she
didn't have all the ingredients she made
it work though I will say it like
bothers me that those onions were cut so
large it was like a culinary pet peeve
of mine I would not want to like fight
and I meant I don't like red onions
that's just that's just the truth right
there but when he I forgive you
but even though whitney isn't
plant-based I really love that she's
experimenting with trying more
plant-based meals and ingredients I will
say though that there has been a lot of
criticism of the beyond meat products
because of the added fat salt and
additives in it I mean it's got 17
different ingredients actually but
critics often argue that if you were to
make beef based meatballs it would just
be like ground beef maybe some salt and
pepper maybe a little bread crumbs
personally I love that we have vegan
options that taste like meat if you're
trying to cut back on beef I think it's
a great option to throw in the mix but I
probably wouldn't replace all of your
meals with these kind of faux meats I
would way rather see us enjoying more
naturally occurring sources of
plant-based protein like beans and
lentils things that don't have all those
additives and salt but honestly this
dinner is really easy and it sounds so
delicious again it provides a really
good distribution of macronutrients and
also it seems like if you're like really
really filling I am also a huge huge fan
of spaghetti squash I think it's a great
way to sneak in some extra fiber and
it's so easy to cook so I love that now
I will say if there isn't a workout
midday where the post-workout protein
timing is a consideration I would say
then you could probably skip the protein
shake and then try making dinner a
little bit earlier if you're hungry that
or we could probably have a little bit
less protein in the dinner to
accommodate the protein shake that we
had just like moments or maybe like half
an hour before if we add the protein
shake in
this meal it's about sixty grams protein
in a short period of time if that was
what she was feeling and she was craving
the extra protein amazing like you go
for it but I think for a lot of people
who aren't training so hard
if the workout isn't in like an awkward
late afternoon timeslot my
recommendation would be to spread out
the protein a little bit more maybe have
an earlier dinner and then have the
protein shake after dinner before bed
truly optimize the utilization of that
protein I get though that like life gets
busy and so nice this is just how it all
shakes out so get it in when you can I
guess with a beautiful wonderful the
best treat in the whole world my current
obsession hold the cone from traders
thank you love it
can't finish the day off without not
having a sweet you know I'm saying you
know I need a sweet so I get you girl I
feel you on the sweet thing and I really
makes me so happy to see Whitney's
attitude towards sweets also that she is
just as obsessed with Trader Joe's as I
am but honestly there is absolutely
nothing wrong with enjoying a fun food
or two every single day and I think this
is like a great option for my ice cream
or my chocolate lovers hello because
sometimes you know you just need like a
little some something and this is the
perfect few bites to get your fix if you
if you're craving some chocolate if you
need a little ice cream both of which I
want right now
my only criticism is that I really wish
Whitney was not tempting me with so many
awesome Trader Joe's products when us
Canadians are otherwise like majorly
deprived but on that note let's take a
look-see at our macros in this state
Whitney's getting approximately 2,000
155 calories 40% of which is coming from
carbs 32% from fat and 28% from protein
so that is all within the
recommendations I mean it's technically
a little bit high on the protein side
and a little bit low on the carb side
but if it's working for her it's working
for me it also seems that when he has a
really good grasp on nutrition and knows
how to make meals are filling and
delicious while still ultimately like
listening to her body and going with the
flow I also really want
acknowledge that this lifestyle or
experience may seem really far away for
so many of you but I do believe with
some practice and mindfulness in the
kitchen you'll get there now let's talk
about what I really like about Whitney's
day number one her relationship with
food and her body has really done a 180
if we look back on Whitney's old videos
it's really hard to believe how far
she's come instead of focusing on being
thin she's now really focusing on
feeling her healthiest and strongest
self I love that she's kind of turned
away from fearing carbs and now is like
openly welcoming them and embracing them
at her meals she also is a really great
viewpoint on like all types of foods and
doesn't categorize them as good versus
bad you know all foods fit and you know
I am like totally down for that message
number two she eats balanced satiating
meals
Wendy's meals aren't the sad tiny
portions we see from so many youtubers
right now she knows that she's an active
woman who needs a solid amount of food
to sustain her activity and help her
body thrive she includes fiber protein
and healthy fats and all of her meals
which really keeps her going during
those busy long days I am so
appreciative to see a youtuber
normalising eating to satiety honestly
that deserves an applause number three
she seems to have a lot of fun in the
kitchen I love that Whitney seems to
treat cooking and food prep as like a
fun thing rather than a chore I really
really really love seeing her experiment
and have fun doing it
even if she's not following the recipe
she just finds a way to make it work and
embraces the messy journey I love it
she's so fun to watch I really think
that the more fun that you have in the
kitchen
the more likely you are to experiment
with your food skills and practice
making different healthy dishes so yay
now let's talk about what I think she
can maybe work on and honestly I
couldn't really think of much I think
she's doing great things and I like love
her channel I can watch her all day
maybe she could have more carbs and a
little bit less protein but I mean if
this is working for her I'm happy about
it and this is just going off what I see
here without having done an actual
assessment or
her unique protein needs this is just
based on like one example of the protein
shake plus another 38 grams of protein
at dinner being so close together seemed
a little excessive when maybe we could
have just upped the carbs a little bit
dinner to compensate for the high
protein shake but again like this is one
day and I'm getting super critical for
the sake of saying something if it works
for Whitney it's working for me all in
all I really love
Whitney's channel and her message and I
will definitely be following her journey
towards promoting a healthier
relationship with your body and food so
lovelies a big thank you again to trade
for sponsoring this video as always if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with some examples or other youtubers
that you'd like you to review subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]